L
WELL, OM TED OR THROW  AN HE A S
METLETS.
CHARACTERS REVEALED IN A. PENCE
CIDE WHAT PPENED ON JANUARIS CMF
URTHATTRFO.GAIN. THE ARES
WE'VE SEH DISTANCE HLF
AWHILE BUT I HAVEN'TNEW YORK POB
S REALLY
BYI O ALMOST
ATCH D MUCH
WITH H BCACAND HE'S SUCH A SEHAE
.ON TWILL GET RATINGS.FO, E GREA
EDITORIALSM HATO EM.RGET, T OUT
WHEN Y
I'LL BD WHEN IEAR IMOSTS S
FEW MINUTES LIZ CHENEY
>> LOOK, ISTYING
TRUMP IS UNFIFOFIERNT MURDOCHNK
D THE TH"
ING AFE ONNIGHT. >> SEET YOU DIN
ESN D IMPAYOU AG TV E , HOW
THOUGHT THEY WGOING  WEN MLDESTO
DO.
LOOK,  ONEMPLET FOHOW TOAKMENT
YOU GOT  BE DRAMA BUT YOU GOAT'E
SWORN TESTCC B
HISTORY AND BLOWSE EXTE WHAT T
WING MEDIANGS Y
ABOUT D ON
6th,02 JOU
R PTEMBER.
KWIHE SCOPEHE
6th WAAN ISO HPESTEAD, THERE AM